انها الثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياض انا صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
امراه تفجر نفسها في اكثر شوارع اسطنبول
ازدحاما والسلطات تفتح تحقيقا في هجوم
ارهابي
ايران تصدر اول حكم بالاعدام مرتبط
بالاحتجاجات الحاليه واكثر من 2000 شخص
يواجهون نفس المصير
بيض متاح بعد ضمان الاغلبيه في مجلس
الشيوخ وفلوس تقول ان هناك فرصه للفوز
بمواقاعد النواب
الغرب يدفع باتجاه التفاوض مع روسيا
واشنطن تنصحوا كيف مطالبه واقعيه للحوار
والاوروبيون يستعجلونها
[موسيقى]
اوقاتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه في اكثر
شوارع اسطنبول ازدحاما بالسياحي والمشاه
والمتسوقين وقع انفجار في شارع الاستقلال
بميدان تقسيم الشهير التفجير الذي رجحت
المعلومات الاوليه انه عمليه ارهابيه او
قطع سته قتلى واكثر من 80 مصابا المدعي
العام في اسطنبول فتح تحقيقها في الانفجار
فيما اخذت الشرطه منطقه تقسيم بالكامل اما
بالنسبه لتفاصيل الانفجار فقد جمع عن
قنبله وضعت داخل حقيبه بحسب مراسل العربيه
لما قال رئيس تركيا رجب طيب اردوغان ان
امراه طالعه في الهجوم وفق تحقيقه الاوليه
ونشر الاعلام التركي صوره قال انها
الانتحاريه التي نفذت الهجوم كما نراها
كان هناك تفجير في شارع الاستقلال ووقع
قتله وجرحى اتمنى شفاء العاجل لهم وتم نقل
الضحايا الى المشافي وسنكشف القائمين على
التفجير وسينالون عقابهم في اسرع وقت
الارهاب لن يصل لمبتغاه والعناصر التي
تحاول النيل من الوحده التركيه لن تحقق
طموحها وسينال المجرمون عقابهم
وقد افاده
قطاعات الانترنت بتقيد من الصوت التواصل
الاجتماعي في تركيا بعد الانفجار الذي
شهدته منطقه تقسيم وسط اسطنبول وقل مرصد
لوكس ان الشبكات الاجتماعيه التي جرى
تفيدها شملت تويتر انستغرام
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
واثرا انفجار اسطنبول
عن اداره المملكه باشد العبارات التفجيره
الارهابي الذي استهدف منطقه تقسيم وادى
الى وفاته وجرح عدد من المدنيين الخارجيه
السعوديه اكدت في بيان ان المملكه تقف مع
تركيا ضد هذا العمل الجبان معربه عن
تعازيها لذوي الضحايا والتمنيات بالشفاء
العاجل للمصابي
[موسيقى]
من اسطنبول معنا الدكتور بكير اتجان مدير
معهد اسطنبول للفكر دكتور اهلا بك معنا في
اخبار الساعه من العربيه من رساله التي
تريد الجهه
الهجوم هذا التفجير ما الرساله التي تريد
ان توصلها من خلال استهداف تقسيم القلب
النابض لاسطنبول بالسياح في يوم احد
اولا يجب ان ناخذها بعد
يعني اشكال خلينا نقول اولا من الاول او
عده نواحي الناحيه الاقتصاديه والناحيه
العسكريه والناحيه السياسيه
والناحيه الاجتماعيه ايضا هناك رسائل من
الناحيه اولا اقتصاديه لانها منطقه معروفه
بسواح فهذه ربما تساعد على
حدث الاقتصاد التي هي غير جيده الان في
تركيا ثانيا من الناحيه العسكريه التركيه
في الفتره الاخيره تدعي وما زالت تقول بان
قضت على الارهابيين في شمال سوريا في شمال
العراق وفي داخل تركيا
وتدرجيا سوف تقضي عليهم تماما المتواجدون
خلصت عددهم الى حد كبير جدا وهذه ايضا
من كلامك ان هناك ترجيحات لهذه الجهه التي
تقف وراء تفجير تقسيم دكتور
الطبيعي يعني ليست واحده عند الترجيحات
لان
تريد ان تضرب في نفس الوقت من الناحيه
الاقتصاديه من الناحيه السياسيه العسكريه
والاجتماعيه ايضا خاصه
الانتخابيه والسياسيه والعسكريه ما عساها
تكون هذه الجهه
يعني هذه الجهه حسب
المعطيات الى الان تشير الى حزب العمال
الكردستاني
التي كانت وضعها صعب في الفتره الاخيره في
سوريا في العراق وفي اقصد شمال سوريا شمال
العراق وداخل تركيا
الجيش عناصر الامن التركي يعني لا تستهدف
المدنيين في شارع معروف انه مدني ويعج
بالسياح ويكون مكتظ في وقت الذروه في يوم
الاحد في يوم عطله
يعني لو وافق على هذا الرايب بالعكس هناك
عده عمليات قامت بها البيكي
عن عمليات عديده ضد المدنيين والان
البكيكي لا تضرب الجيش او ااا الشرطه في
اي مكان بالعكس تضرب المدنيين وجميع
الانفجارات التي حصلت من طرف داخل تركيا
كلها ضد المدنيين لن تكون ضد العسكريين في
اي مكان يعني وراح ضحيتها مدنين يعني هي
تقول بانها هي ضربت مثلا همم بس تاخذ
العسكريين ولكن هؤلاء لا يحملون السيد
احمد مدنيين ضربت قبل ايضا سنين مناطق
تفجيرات تدعي بانها عسكريين ولكنها ولا
حتى العمليه التي قامت فيها في تفجيرهم في
هذه الكهف الذين قتلوا هؤلاء يعني قبضت
عليهم حزب العمال داخل تركيا هؤلاء ينتمون
الى الجيش ولكن قبضه وهو مدنيين وهم في
الباص او في اماكن
سفر لن يكونوا يحمل السلاح معهم ولما
ذهبوا لن يكونوا حامل السلاح اذا هذه
منظمه تقتل المدنيين قبل العسكريين نعم
طيب دعنا ننتظر نتائج التحقيقات التي
تحقيق الرسمي الذي بدا في همم هذه
التفجير نعم لكن كان هناك شيء لافت كذلك
دكتور بكير لماذا قيدت السلطات التركيه
التغطيه الاعلاميه لهذا التفجير في تقسيم
وكذلك قيدت الوصول الى اي محتوى همم يتعلق
كذلك بالتفجير عبر وسائل التواصل
يعني هناك عده اسباب ولكن اريد ان اشكر
سببين او ثلاثه مهمين اولا هذه العمليات
عاده لما تنفذها بهذا الشكل يعني
قنابل بهذا الشكل تكون اكثر من عمليه يعني
في اكثر من مكان ربما تكون في مكان قريب
لها ايضا او حتى
مكانين الثلاثه لذلك كانت على الامن ان
تاخذ الاحتياطات بسرعه لكي لا تكون هناك
مكان اخر وخاصه من المدنيين ثانيا والتي
هي ايضا اهم يعني هؤلاء لابد همم القبض
على الناس الذين كانوا لن تكون سيده وحيده
مش ممكن لابد هناك مساعدين لابد من هناك
ناس يعني كانوا داعمين لهذه العمليه
متورطين فيها فلا بد اذا كانت هناك مفتوح
التواصل مفتوح وكل شيء فسوف يهربون فلذلك
لابد اغلاق هذه الاماكن التواصل ان كانت
عن طريق الانترنت او عن طريق حتى
التليفزيون والاعلام او حتى عن طريق اغلاق
هذه الشوارع والبوابات التي ممكن ان يهرب
منها فهذه كانت طبيعيه وهذه الدوله لابد
الام تاخذ احتياطاتها وضروريه جدا لكي لا
تكون العمليات اكثر من عمليه في نفس الوقت
وقد حصلت في تركيا من هذه النوع من
العمليات تفجيرات عندما تذهب بالبوليس
لنفس العمليه كانت تفجير اخر وثاني وثالث
ورابع حصلت عده مرات فراح ضحيتها ايضا
مدنيين فعل تركيا كانت ان تاخذ الاحتياطات
اللازمه واخذتها لذلك ضروريه جدا لكي تعرف
المنشا ومن همم الضلعين ومن المساعدين
لهذه العمليه لانها لن تكون لشخص او سيده
واحده والامور بهذا السرعه وبهذا الشمس
في انتظار ان همم نعرف حقيقه همم الجهه
التي تقف وراء هذا التفجير في اسطنبول
شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور بكير اتجان مدير
معهد اسطنبول شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]
اخبار الساعه نتابع من السودان هل برهان
يحسم الجدل ويؤكد ليس هناك تسويه ثنائيه
مع المكونين المدني
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في اخبار الساعه تمضي
ايران في حمله القمح ضد المحتاجين بكل
الوسائل فعاله صعيد المحاكمات اصدر القضاء
الايراني اول حكم بالاعدام على متظاهر على
خلفيه الاحتجاجات وياتي الحكم بعد ساعات
من توجيه القضاء الايرانيه لاتهامه لنحوي
800 متظاهر جديد في 30 محافظات وبحسب
ارقام القضاء الايراني
2200 شخص نصفهم في طهران منذ بدء
الاحتجاجات وافاد موقعه ميزان التابع
للقضاء الايراني
264 متظاهرا سيحاكمون اعتبارا من الخميس
المقبل اثاره الشغب اضافه موقع ميزان ان
محتجين سيحاكمون بيتهم التامر ضد الدوله
والتحريض على القتل بالاضافه الى تهم
الدعايه ضد النظام واستهدفك والامن اشار
موقع ميزان التابع للقضايا الايراني
الموجهه للمحتاجين قد تصل عقوبتها الى
الاعدام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
معنى من لندن البحث
الاستاذ عارف اهلا بك معنا اول حكم اعدام
ضد
الناشطين في هذه المظاهرات الاحتجاجيه في
ايران هل حكم الاعدام سيخيف المحتاجين في
ايران
تحيه طيبه لك والمشاهدين العربيه الكرام
الواقع هذا الحكم ليس الاول اذا ما اخذنا
بعين الاعتبار بان خلال على الاقل 5 سنوات
الماضيه شهدت ايران كل سته اشهر واحيانا
اقل من هذه المده مظاهرات عارمه وبالتالي
اصدرت حكم الاعدام وهذا همم لم يردع
المتظاهرين بانه يخرجون مره ثانيه
وبالتالي يحتقد بان هذه
ربما العقوبات او همم الاعدامات التي تصدر
بحق المتظاهرين لا تستطيع ان ترجع
المتظاهرين من من اكمال مسيرتهم خاصه وان
عقوبه الاعدام وفق القانون العقوبات
الاسلاميه همم
تهمه الحرابه وكذلك الافساد في الارض
عقوبه فضفاضه يمكن يستخدمها النظام
الايراني ما كما اراد وكيف ما اراد وفقا
لظروفه السياسيه والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
حوالي 227 نائب من اصل 290 البرلمان
الايراني اا مجلس الشورى الايراني
بالتحديد طلبوا في مطلع نوفمبر بتطبيق
مبدا العين بالعين في التعامل مع المتهمين
المتهمين بالحرابه كما تفضلت والافساد في
الارض يا ترى هل سنشهد اعدامات كثيره بحق
هؤلاء المتظاهرين بهذه التهمه
يعني انا اعتقد بخصوص المجلس عندما اصدر
هذه الهمم الرساله وان وان ترددها حتى
الان لم يعلن اي شخص بانه وقع على هذه
الرساله وهنالك تشكيك ربما حتى باصدار مثل
هذه الرساله او لا يريدون ان ان يصدروها
ان هي صدرت لكي همم يمنع ويسكر الابواب
فيما يتعلق بالماده 59 من الدستور
الايراني وهي همم الدعوه الى الاستفتاء من
خلال البرلمان عندما يكون ثلثيه الاعضاء
يدعون الى استفتاء عامه ممكن ان تذهب
البلاد الى استفتاء الى تغيرات دستوريه
وبالتالي اعتقد بان هذه الرساله نشرت ربما
من قبل المخابرات الايرانيه او حتى بعض
النواب همم لكي تؤكد بان البرلمان لا يريد
ان يذهب بهذا الاتجاه اكثر همم الليله قبل
اقل من همم يعني نصف ساعه من الان ان هناك
اخبار عاجله نقلتها النيويورك تايمز
الامريكيه نقلا عن الاف بي اي عن اكتشاف
محققين خاصين تابعين لايران في نيويورك
وكاليفورنيا لتعقب المعارضين الايرانيين
داخل امريكا كيف تعلق على على هذا الخبر
وهل ايران بصدد ربما ملاحقه المعارضين
وربما اغتيالهم همم خارج الاراضي
الايرانيه كذلك
الفعل يعني اعتقد بان اولا اذا ما قرانا
الصحافه الايرانيه هي هددت
بالاسم واتت به على الاقل بريطانيا وكذلك
عده دول اوروبيه اضافه الى ما نعلمه عن
تحركات ايران في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه همم وحددت معارضيها بل هي نفذت
هذا الامر في هولندا مع الشهيد احمد مولى
ميسي وكذلك مع الكثير من معارضيها
واقتالتهم في في وضع النهار في اوروبا من
هنا ان اعتقد بان قد يكون احدى خيارات
النظام الايراني التحرك مع المعارضه
والمعارضه تعي هذا الامر لكن اعتقد بان
همم هيبه النظام الايراني سقطت في عيونهم
ولا توجد خشيه بهذا الاسم بهذا الامر عارف
نصر الباحث في شان الايراني مباشره من
لندن شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
هذا واشنط ايران هجوما على رئيس الفرنسيه
بسبب عقده لقاء مع ناشطات ايرانيات في
باريس اعتبرت الخارجيه الايرانيه اللقاء
انتهاكا
لمسؤوليات فرنسا الدوليه
تقدر وتنظر باحترام احتجاجات الشعب
الايراني
فرنسيين امس
[موسيقى]
الى امريكا الان تبخرت احلام الجمهوريين
في السيطره على مجلس الشيوخ بعدما قالت
ديمقراطيون كلمتهم وحققوا ما بدا مستبعدا
في استطلاعات الراي الديمقراطيون حافظوا
على المكاسب اذا داخل مجلس الشيوخ بعد ما
وصلوا الى المقعد ال 50 بينما وصل
الجمهوريون للمقعد 49 وحتى لو فازوا
بالمقعد المتبقي في ولايه جورجيا ستكون
نائبه الرئيس كمالهارس قادره على ترجيح
كفه الديمقراطيين ويعدو نجاحه الحزب
الديمقراطي في مجلس الشيوخ واحدا من اقوى
النجاحات لحزب يمسك بالبيت الابيض في
الانتخابات النصفيه خلال عقدين من الزمن
وعمليا فان سيطره الديمقراطيين على مجلس
الشيوخ من شانها ان تريح نوعا ما الرئيس
الامريكي
القضائيين في المحاكم الفيدراليه فضلا عن
تعيناته الاداريه حيث لا يكون بامكان
الجمهوريين اعاقه تعيين اي شخص يختاره
بايضا كما ان نقاطينه سيحضون بميزه اضافيه
تتمثل في اقرار بعض مشاريع القوانين
المثيره للجدل التي يسمح باجازتها بغلبيه
بسيطه من الاصوات بدلا من ال 60 صوتا
اللازمه لمعظم القوانين اضافه الى ما سبق
فان فوزا الديمقراطيين يعني ايضا تعزيز
بيض لموقفه هو والحزب الديمقراطي قبل
الانتخابات الرئاسيه بعد عامين ورغم ذلك
يبقى من المتوقع ان يحضر جمهوريون بسيطره
بفارق بسيط في مجلس النواب الغرفه الادنى
وهو ما قد يزعج بايضا قليلا
لكن في المقابل يحمل الجمهوريون يحملون
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
المسؤوليه عن الفشل في انتخابات التجديد
النصفي
هل الحضور اللافت للرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب في حملات المرشحين الجمهوريين ام
الاغتسال الداخلي بين اعضاء الحزب هو ما
افشل خطتك اكتساح المد الاحمر للصناديق
اقتراع الكونغرس
هزيمه تسببت باحباط الجمهوريين من نتائج
الانتخابات النصفيه فعند الحديث عن ابرز
الخاسرين في مجلس الشيوخ رغم دعم ترامب
لهم
ادمنت عن ولايه نيفادا وبليك ماسترز عن
ولايه ارينا ومحمد اوز عن ولايه بن سلمان
حتى مقاعد مجلس النواب لم تسلم من الفشل
رغم الاقتراب من حصد الاغلبيه فالنتيجه لم
تكون كاسحه
تلك النتائج المخيبه لامال الجمهوريين
فتحت الباب للتساؤل حول مستقبل الرئيس
السابق ترامب السياسيه ومواقف اعضاء حزبه
المتضاربه من وجوده على الساحه السياسيه
ولعبه ادوار مستقبليه كانت نتائج
الانتخابات النصفيه اكبر مؤشرين على ان
ترامب لا ينبغي ان يكون المرشح الجمهوريه
عام 2024 كثير من الناس يريدون دفنه ترامب
وارثه في قبر لكنه مازال فوق الارض ولديه
كثير من النفوذ السياسي بين الناخبين داخل
الحزب
هنالك ايضا مخاوف من دخول الحزب الجمهوري
في دوامه الفوضى الداخليه فقبل اشهر من
الانتخابات النصفيه هاجم الزعيم
الجمهوريين في مجلس الشيوخ السيناتور
مجماكونل اختيارات ترامب لعدد من المرشحين
و دعمهم في السباقات التمهيديه للحزب لكن
مكان لنفسه تعرض للانتقاد من قبل بليك
ماسترز الخاسر في سباق اريزونا والذي
اتهمم كونيل بانه السبب في خسارته بعد ان
وجه اموال الحزب لدعم مرشحه جمهوريه في
الاسكا ضد مرشحه جمهوريه اخرى في اطار
الصراع الداخليه في الحزب
بينما يتناحر الجمهوريون فيما بينهم صعد
اسم الجمهوري روندي سانتس الذي فاز بمنصب
حاكم فلوريدا كاحد اشد منافسي الرئيس
ترامب وصاحب الحظوظ الاكبر حسب التوقعات
بان يسعى لخوض انتخابات الرئاسه عام 2024
معنى من فرجينيا مراسل العربيه حسين طود
حسين اهلا بك معنا في اخبار الساعه اهم
المواقف وردود الافعال على احتفاظ او حصول
الديمقراطيين على اغلبيه ولو بسيطه في
مجلس الشيوخ
تحيه لك صهيب اداء الديمقراطيين في مجلس
الشيوخ في الحقيقه فقط توقعات تاريخيا
دائما او بمنظمه الاوقات كان حزب الرئيس
يخسر في الانتخابات التشديد النصفي
المقاعد الان اذا استطاع الديمقراطيون ان
يحتفظوا بمقعد جورجيا في السادس من ديسمبر
سيزيدون عدد المقاعد بعدما قلبه مقعد
التنس البانيا لصالحهم اولى ردود الفعل
كانت صراحه لافته من زعيم الديمقراطيين في
مجلس الشيوخ التكشومر الذي قال ان هذه
الانتخابات وهذه النتيجه تبرئ
الديمقراطيين وسياستهم التي يتهممها
الجمهوريون بانها ادت الى تضخم الى وضع
اقتصادي صعب ايضا بالنسبه لسنه الجمهوريه
نزلت الديمقراطيه الى زمن اعتبرت ان هذا
النصر هو النصر
عديده من قبل الديمقراطيين ترحب بهذا
النظر ولكن في المقابل الجمهوريون هناك
جدل كبير الان يت بينهم وهناك من يدوم
دونالد ترامب ويقول وجوده كان سلبيا واثر
على الحسين الجمهوريون متقدمون في مجلس
النواب ولكن نانسي فيلوسي زعمت طبعا
الديمقراطين سابقا في مجلس النواب السابق
تقول انه ربما تكون هناك فرصه
للديمقراطيين ايضا في مجلس النواب ماذا
تقول الترجيحات حتى الان
الترجيحات صهيب تميل
حتى الان ولكن ننسكي ما زالت متفائله بانه
يمكن ان يحدث فرق لان الاصوات لم تفرز
كلها بعد هناك اصوات لاسيما انها في
كاليفورنيا وايضا في همم نيو ماكسيكو
اوريون وحتى بالنسبه همم
التنافس ولكن جميع تقريبا او غالبيه
التحليلات تشير الى احتمال فوز الجمهوريين
بمجلس النواب
على اغلبيه ولكن اغلبيه بسيطه لن تكون
اغذيه كبيره كامله كانوا يتوقعون قبل
الانتخابات بان يكون هناك موجه حمراء يحسد
فيها عندا كبيره من الاصوات لا ستكون
اغلبيه بسيطه جدا وليست كبيره الحسين
طاوود مباشره شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
الى الحرب في اوكرانيا بدا الغرب يدفع
باتجاه التفاوض مع روسيا صحيفه
في مطالبه واقعيه اولويه للمفاوضات واوضحت
صحيفه ان نصيحه واشنطن جاءت على لسان
المستشعر بالامن القومي الامريكي
خلال زيارته الاخيره
فرصه للتفاوض بين روسيا واوكرانيا خلال
الاشهر المقبله اضافه الصحيفه وان واشنطن
تعتقد ان بدايه فصل الشتاء يمكن ان تكون
النقطه تحول الصراعي في اوكرانيا ونقلتها
الصحيفه كذلك عن احد الدماسين الاوروبيين
الغربيين قوله ان الامر متروك للاوكرانيين
لبدء محادثات السلام موضحا انه من الجيد
بدئها بسرعه على حد
[موسيقى]
وميدانيا خلصن عادت الى احضان اوكرانيا في
انتصار يحمل طعما خاصا بالنسبه لكيف قياسا
برمزيه المكان والزمان ايضا
تعد احد اهم عناوين هذه الحرب
كانت العاصمه الاقليميه الوحيده التي كانت
تحتلها روسيا وكانت ابرز المدن التي سقطت
مباشره بعد العمليه العسكريه الروسيه
انسحاب هام عقبته احتفالات عامه داخل
المدينه من طرف حشود هللت وهتفت للجنود
الاوكرانيين العائدين الى المدينه
[موسيقى]
السلطات الاوكرانيه لم تنتهي مع استعاده
السيطره على المدينه بل وجدوا امامهم مهما
اخرى
لم تنفجر تركها الروس وراءهم كما تم نشره
نحو 200 شرطيه اخرى
في المدينه بعد خروج القوات الروسيه ذكرت
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه انه من المرجح
جدا ان تكون القوه الروسيه قد دمر في
الطريق وجسر سكه حديديه مقامين فوق نهر
ديبرو خلال عمليه انسحابه من جهه الثانيه
يعتبر وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه خطوه
استعاده نصرا حقيقيا سيضع كيف في موقف قوه
في حال جلوس الطرفين الى طاوله
وينك
[موسيقى]
يبدو ان وضع القوات الروسيه افضل حالا مما
هو عليه في خرفن في القوات المواليه
لروسيا سجل التقدم على اطراف في مدينتي
الدكه وماريانكا التي يسيطر عليها الجيش
الاوروبي العاصمه دميه
لروسيا عن استمرار المعارك على اطراف
لدفع الجيش الاوكرانيه للانسحابي من
المدينه
واضافت ان عمليه الضغط مستمره في مدينه
بوهلي دار جنوب مقاطعه دميه
[موسيقى]
تحذير شديد اللهجه وجهه رئيس مجلس السياده
وقائد القوات المسلحه السودانيه عبد
الفتاح البرهان للسياسيين بالابتعاد عن
الجيش ومحاولات التحريض مشيرا في كلمه
القاها في قاعده المرخيات العسكريه الى
انقسام القوى السياسيه وغياب التوافق بين
الاطراف السودانيه يضر بالمؤسسات كافه
البرهان دعا قوى الحريه والتغيير الى طرح
رؤيه الموحده كما دعاء ايضا الى تشكيل
حكومه المدنيه غير حزبيه تبتعد عن
المحافظه
ما في حزب كان مشارك في الفتره السابقه
السودان كله السودانيين كلهم نحب نكر
دعوتنا اليوم
في هذا النزاع النزاع الغير محدود ما عنده
حق كله زول متمسك برايه واحده
من الخرطوم معنا مراسلنا محمد عثمان محمد
اهلا بك معنا كيف هي ردود الفعل خاصه من
الاحزاب والقوه السياسيه على تحذير
البرهان اليوم
اهلا بك صهيب بطبيعه الحاله البرهان ارسل
العديد من الرسائل فهمت على انها هي رسائل
للداخل وللخارج ايضا البرهان تحدث في عدد
من الرسائل الاساسيه والمرتكزات الاساسيه
اولها البرهان نفى ان ما يحدث من تفاهمات
ما بين المكون العسكري وكذلك المجلس
المجلس المركزي لقوى الحريه والتغيير هي
لا تعتبر التسويه همم ثنائيه اي تعيد نظام
الحكم الى ما قبل الخامس والعشرين من
اكتوبر ايضا البرهان تحدث وحذر الاحزاب
السياسيه من عدم يعني استخدام الجيش
كماطيه للوصول الى الاغراض السياسيه بمجرد
ما ارسل البرهان هذه الرسائل الواضحه
للاحزاب السياسيه تفاعلت الاحزاب السياسيه
هنا في السودان دخلت الحريه والتغيير
مجموعه التوافق الوطني او ما تعرف بالكتله
الديمقراطيه في اجتماعات تحدثت همم فيها
بشكل واضح وصريح عن ما يدور يعني خلف
ابو بعيدا عن اعين الصحفيين وبعيدا ايضا
عن عدسات الكاميرات من تفاهمات ما بين
المكون العسكري والمجلس المركزي لقوى
الحريه والتغيير هي ترفض ان تكون هنالك اي
تسويه ثنائيه همم بين هذه المكونات وتعتبر
انه من الضروري ان يتم الاحتكام الى عدد
من المبادرات وليست فقط وثيقه اللجنه
التسيريه للمحامين وايضا كتب على صفحته في
الفيسبوك الامين العام لمجموعه التوافق
الوطني مبارك اردول انتقد الاليه الثلاثيه
حيث انها جلست مع عدد من الاحزاب السياسيه
التي وصفها مبارك اردوغول انهم حلفاء
للمجلس المركزي لقوه الحريه والتغيير وطلب
ايضا بضروره ان يكون الحوار شامل ويشمل
جميع القوى السياسيه ايضا
تحدثنا الى مسؤول الاعلام بحزب الامه
القومي تحدث عن ان حديث البرهان به اشارات
ايجابيه شدد ايضا على ان ما يحدث ايضا
الان من تفاهمات هو ليس تسويه بين المكون
العسكري والمجلس المركزي والحريه والتغيير
وانما هي عمليه سياسيه تفضي الى انهاء
الوضع القائمه الان صهيب محمد عثمان من
الخرطوم شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه خلاف اوروبي حول
الساعين للهجره وفرنسا تنتقم من ايطاليا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد حذرت مديره صندوق النقد
الدوليه كريستالينا جورجينا من ان
المنافسه بين الولايات المتحده والصين قد
تؤدي الى تفتيت الاقتصاد العالمي صندوق
النقد الدولي بان الاقتصاد العالمي يواجه
خطر
5% على اساس السنوي اذا استمر الانقسام
الحالي في التنافس الاقتصادي
[موسيقى]
لكن في المقابل القلم مستشار الامير
القومي للرئيس الامريكي جاكسون لبنان
الرئيس الامريكي
خلال اجتماع المنتظر في بالي على هامشي
قمه العشرين ان واشنطن
يعمل بالخروج من هذا الاجتماع باتفاق
الدولتين على التعاون بشان قضايا جوهريه
وعموما تلقب كبير يسبق العقد قمه مجموعه
ال 20 المقرره غدا في بالي لكن هناك قمه
اخرى لا تقل اهميه تسبق هذا الحدث الكبير
نتعرف عليها
[موسيقى]
معنى من فريق دكتور حسن عبيد الاستاذ
الجامعي والبحث في العلوم الماليه
والاقتصاديه دكتور حسن اهلا بكم معنا في
اخبار الساعه من العربيه برايكم ما اهم
القضايا او القضايا الاكثر حاحا التي
ستناقش في هذه القمه قمه مجموعه العشرين
في بالي غدا الاثنين
اسعد الله مساكم بالخير بكل خير ومساء
المشاهدين يعني بطبيعه الحال اهم الامور
التي يجب مناقشه التي سيتم نشاطها مناقشتي
على مستوى الاقتصادي والمالي والنغطي هي
اولا على مستوى الاقتصادي سيتم مناقشه
موضوع اسعار الطاقه موضوع اسعار الغذاء
والحبوب وموضوع سلاسل التورين اما على
المستوى المالي فاعتقد ان هناك امر مهم
جدا سيتم مناقشته وهو موضوع الديون وازمه
الديون ومن المتوقع ان يكون هناك ازمه
الديون ايضا مع ارتفاع سعر الفائده واما
المستوى النقدي
من المتوقع ايضا مناقشه موضوع اسعار
الفائده المرتفعه التي رفعتها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والتي حذفت حذذها بعض
الدول لكن يا سيدي من الجدير بالذكر هنا
اجتماع وزراء الماليه 20 في 13 اكتوبر من
هذا العام في نيويورك في واشنطن همم
وللاسف لم يكن لم يتوصلوا الى حل وبقيت
هذه الاجتماعات مفتوحه
على ذكر سعر الفائده وقرار الفيدرالي
الامريكي المقبل لانه يؤثر على كما تفضلت
على اقتصادات اخرى عبر العالم ما المامول
من نتائج او حلول من قمه بالي
المامول والحلول هي اعاده النظر باسعار
الفائده التي رفعتها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ولكن هناك تجربه مع الولايات
المتحده في ازمه العمل 2008 وهي لا تنصع
ولا يعني لا تقوم الا بما يخدم مصالحه
والاقتصاد يعني الاقتصاد الامريكي كما هو
وهذا امر معروف يعني يكون دوله تقوم بفرض
همم
يعني السياسات الاقتصاديه التي تهمها اكثر
من غيرها ولذلك ليس من المتامل في هذا
الوضع على الاقتصادي الصعب والتشاذر ال-
ال- العالمي وخاصه بين الولايات المتحده
من ناحيه والصين من ناحيه اخرى وايضا في
خضم هذه الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه ليس من
المتوقع ان الحصول الى حل كبير بهذا الامر
طيب همم ولكن على ذكر اللقاء همم الصيني
الامريكي همم برايك هل يمكن يعني تلطيف
الاجواء قليلا همم في ظل يعني حاله الترقب
التي تشهدها الاسواق العالم هل يمكن لربما
هذا اللقاء الامريكي الصيني ضمن لقاءات
قائد قاده مجموعه ال 20 يمكن ان يحسن
الامور قليلا ام لا
من المتوقع ان يكون ان يكون هناك تحسن
للاسواق نعم ولكن يعني نظمت الاسواق وخاصه
عندما راينا انه هناك هدوء نسبي على على
الناحيه التايوانيه يعني بما يتحلق في
تايوان وهذا امر جيد جدا بالنسبه للاسواق
الصينيه والاسواق الامريكيه ولكن استمرار
الصين بسياسه زيرو كونفيد ايضا قد يؤثر
على سلاسل تمريد ولم اا يعني تاخذ همم
الصين قرار تخفيض هذه الصلابه بهذا
الموضوع ولا اعتقد انها ستخفف من هذه
الصلبه وبالتالي سلاسل توريد قد تؤدي همم
ولكن سيدي دعني مهم جدا همم من المتوقع
العمل عليه يعني وهذا امرني يعرفه
المصريون المحاسبون ان القرا ال- الاجتماع
الذي تم في واشنطن همم درس ايضا موضوع
التشريعات الماليه والمصرفيه وهذا همم
يعني امر لا من ال- من اللفت الانتباهي
العيد نعم شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور حسن عبيد
الاستاذ الجامعي والبحث في العلوم الماليه
والاقتصاديه وانت معنا من باريس
[موسيقى]
اضطرت كلهم من ايطاليا واليونان وماطا
وقبرص بيان المشتركا اكدت فيه رفضها ان
تكون الدول الدخول الاولى للمهاجرين غير
الشرعيه هي المحطات الوحيده الممكنه
للاستقبلك واضافه الدول الاربعه في بيانها
ان عدد المهاجرين الذين تستقبلهم بعض
الدول الاوروبيه هو ضئيل قياسا بالعدد
الفعلي للوافدين غير الشرعيه الى اوروبا
البيان على خلفيه الخلاف حول الاتفاق
الاوروبي لمساعده طالبي اللجوء
[موسيقى]
الساعه انتهت كانت هذه ابرز اخبارها
امراه تفجرون نفسها في اكثر شوارع اسطنبول
ازدحاما والسلطات تفتح تحقيقا في هجوم
ارهابي
ايران تصدر اول حكم بالاعدام مرتبط
بالاحتجاجات الحاليه واكثر من 2000 شخص
يواجهون نفس المصير
بيض المرتاح بعد ضمان الاغلبيه في مجلس
الشيوخ وفلوس تقول ان هناك فرصه للفوز
بمقاعد النواب
الغربه يدفع باتجاه التفاوض مع روسيا
واشنطن تنصحوا كيف بمطالب واقعيه للحوار
والاوروبيون يستعجلونها
شكرا على المشاهده المزيد دائما يبقى على
العربيه
[موسيقى]